surfers travel to the most remote
corners of the world to find the perfect
wave however rare and fleeting when
conditions are just right the results
are magic but these waves weren't
created by nature they were made inside
a wave pool in central California nearly
200 kilometres from the Pacific Ocean
it's the result of a collaboration
between a fluid mechanics specialist
Adam Fincham an 11-time world champion
surfer Kelly Slater wave pools for
surfing date back more than 50 years but
even the best have paled in comparison
to ocean waves under lab conditions a
wave a few centimetres tall can be
predictably modeled using linear
equations but scaling up
Finch him and his coworkers had many
other factors to contend with from
turbulence to oscillations of the entire
water body which is called saeschie
scientists fine-tuned wave shapes with
Slater's input lab built models and
supercomputers often running week-long
simulations they applied their findings
to an artificial lake originally made
for water skiing that stretches 700
metres long and 150 metres wide a slab
of carefully shaped metal called a
hydrofoil is attached to a contraption
that's the size of a few train cars and
with the help of more than 150 truck
tires runs down a track a cable pulls
the hydrofoil at up to 30 kilometers per
hour for the length of the pool
sculpting a wave that can stand more
than 2 meters tall
the wave shape changes as it passes over
contoured reefs along the bottom of the
pool
giant gutters serve as dampers to reduce
sation and limit bounce back from the
pool walls recently some of the top
professional surfers in the world were
invited to the surf ranch to compete
rides can last for 50 seconds and the
wave alternates between faces to carve
on and barreling sections Stephanie
Gilmore six-time world surf league
champion stayed in a barrel for an
astonishing 14 seconds the surf ranch is
a prototype and is not open to the
public but it's developers plans to
build resorts around similar wave pools
at landlocked locales and the ability to
adjust the wave could provide a
controlled way for beginners to learn
and for professionals to train if these
visions come true
Kelly's wave could fundamentally alter
the surf world and artificial as it may
be redefine the search for the perfect
wave
[Music]
[Music]